[Music]
what is up everybody it's Tana Mac here
for anime out Pro and in this video we
will be talking about whether the grand
priest could surprise us all and reveal
that he is actually a good guy after all
now on the one hand many things point to
the grand priest as being a potential
villain we know that after a big
tournament arc like the Tournament of
power it makes sense for Dragon Ball
super to switch to an arc that is
focused on a single villain and because
the grand priest is the most powerful
being other than Zeno and since there is
heavy foreshadowing that the grand
priest is actually manipulating Zeno it
would make sense for him to be the next
villain in fact a lot of people have
speculated about the grand priests true
intentions and in one of my previous
videos about who will be the final
villain in Dragon Ball super I even said
myself that there is a strong
possibility that the grand priest will
turn out to be a villain however as I've
been watching the tournament of power on
fold one thought kept popping into my
mind over and over again I didn't give
it too much thought until I saw a video
by Masako X about ultra instinct in
which he briefly mentioned some things
about Zeno and the grand priest that
I've also been thinking about and after
I saw that video and realized that I
wasn't the only one I decided to make
this video and explore these questions
in greater detail I will leave a link to
Masako XS channel in the description so
feel free to check him out and if you
enjoyed the Dragon Ball super content on
this channel be sure to leave a like and
if you new don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell also if you
want to support this channel and get
cool anime merch at the same time like
keep calm and ultra instinct or your
girl calls me Sam PI check out our merch
store link in the description now the
grand priest definitely appears to be
manipulating the child there's NO on
multiple occasions the grand priest is
the one that tells us that Xena wishes
to erase those universes that are
defeated in the tournament of power and
because Zeno does not seem to enjoy
destroying
the sake of destroying but merely sees
everything as a game this has led many
to speculate that maybe the grand priest
talked Zeno into erasing the losing
universes in episode 80 we learned that
the angels will be spared even if their
universe is destroyed and we also know
that the grand priest is the father of
at least six of the angels so it would
make sense for the grand priest who is
clearly a highly intelligent being to
want his children to no longer serve as
attendants of beings that he considers
lesser than the angels and so he may
want the universes to be erased in order
to release the angels of this obligation
and who knows maybe after enough angels
are free to help him the grand priests
will attempt to somehow overthrow Zeno
I think that this is a plausible theory
and it still might turn out to be true
that the grand priest is manipulating
Zeno because he is evil if you believe
this theory by all means I'm not
knocking you it makes sense but let's
think about this what if the grand
priest is indeed manipulating Zeno but
he's doing it for a good cause
let me explain we know that there are 12
universes before the tournament of power
begins but we also know that there were
once 18 universes altogether and the six
other universes were erased by Zeno just
because his mood was a little bit
spoiled as weas tells us now obviously
we don't know what exactly happened
there to spoil xennos mood but you can
imagine how insanely dangerous it is to
have a being who on a whim just because
he is in a bad mood decides to erase six
entire universes we have been given many
clues throughout the series that Zeno
functions on a separate plane of
existence from regular mortals so he
simply does not understand or relate to
the suffering of mortals his personality
seems so naive and childish that he
probably doesn't even understand the
concept of death and to him entire
planets are like toys in episode 77 when
the two xenos are destroying planets as
part of their game and they don't
actually see the
brutal consequences of what is happening
but merely projections of the planets as
if they were marbles so it is safe to
assume that Zeno isn't actually evil or
sadistic but simply doesn't fully
understand the consequences of his
actions and this is because he is so far
removed from these consequences now what
if the destruction of the other six
universes as a result of xenos bad mood
led the grand priests to realize that
something has to change otherwise Zeno
may destroy all of existence because of
some silly mood swing we're not sure but
it is possible that the angels of the
other six universes were also erased
because we haven't seen them yet and if
this really happened it would certainly
give the grand priest a reason to be
upset before the start of the tournament
of power many accused Goku of being
responsible for the losing universes
being erased because he played a key
role in ensuring that the tournament
happens but in episode 85 vatos clearly
states that the universe's should in
fact be grateful to Goku because without
the tournament they would have been
erased already the tournament actually
gave them a fair fighting chance so what
if the grand priest saw the tournament
of power as an opportunity to teach the
childish Zeno an important lesson
what if Zeno was really planning to
destroy the other universes that are
taking part in the tournament just like
he decided to destroy the previous six
universes that were erased when instead
the grand priests convinced him to hold
off until the tournament one thing that
I keep seeing throughout the universe
survival arc is just how much sin oh is
enjoying the tournament this is what I
keep thinking about over and over again
Zeno is absolutely loving all the epic
battles the interesting techniques the
cool items like the Patara and just
overall he looks like he is having the
time of his life now think about this
once the tournament ends and all but one
universe are erased that leaves only
five universes in existence include
the four that are not competing the
other nine universes are gone at some
point it will dawn on the Z knows that
the incredibly entertaining event that
they had just witnessed the tournament
of power with eight different universes
going head to head can never take place
in the same way again because most of
the participants are now gone they no
longer exists having seen how much the
two xenos absolutely love watching the
tournament can you really imagine that
they are going to be okay with never
witnessing another tournament like that
again of course in theory there could be
a tournament between the five remaining
universes but that would mean less
fighters less interesting techniques
less unique powers and so on this is the
point at which the grand priest could
make his move what if the grand priest
explains to the disappointed Zeno that
the only way to witness such a grand
tournament again is to bring back the
universes that were erased in return for
bringing them back Zeno could make a
rule that every year or every few years
or however often he wants a tournament
between all the universes has to take
place kind of like a universe Olympic
Games the losing universes wouldn't be
erased so that they could keep competing
in future tournaments but the winning
universe would get a huge prize that
would motivate all of the universes to
do their best to win we know that Zeno
is not above changing his mind after all
he did agree to change the rule that the
losing universes would be erased in the
tournament of power if Bergamo had
succeeded in defeating Goku
so I don't think that it's impossible
for someone as intelligent as the Grand
Prix's to convince him to bring back the
universes that were erased let's face it
from what we've seen so far all the
grand priests would have to do is
convince Zeno that bringing back the
universes would be a lot of fun and he
would definitely do it and what a crazy
twist that would be now if this theory
is correct then the grand priest was
actually a good guy all along having
realized that Zeno was incapable of
relating to mortals and
couldn't see them as anything more than
toys and also realizing that Zeno could
one day just erase all of existence if
he got upset for some reason the grand
priest made sure that the tournament of
power took place in order to teach Zeno
that mortals have value Zeno now knows
that mortals are intelligent and capable
of coming up with complex battle
strategies they have feelings and
emotions and most importantly they can
be very entertaining one of xenos
biggest problems is his own boredom but
now that he sees and knows the value of
mortals Zeno will likely want more
mortals and more universes around to
keep him entertained not less so Zeno
might not only stop erasing the existing
universes but he might actually bring
back the ones that were already erased
because he wants to see what kind of
fighters techniques cool items and so on
they would have to contribute to future
tournaments so what do you guys think
could the grand priest be a good guy was
the tournament of power his way of
teaching Zeno the value of mortals so
that he would no longer erase entire
universes on a whim or do you think that
the grand priest is definitely evil and
is going to become the villain in one of
the upcoming arcs let me know down below
I just want to say that the support for
Dragon Ball super content on this
channel has been growing thank you guys
so much if you enjoyed these videos be
sure to leave a like to let me know and
if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to give us
ideas for future videos the best way to
do that is on Twitter you can follow us
at anime uproar as always thank you all
so much for watching thanks to my good
friend Kid kite for helping out and
until next time see us space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]